ich will nicht ich sage mal mit einem
impfstoff geimpft werden der in einem
land hergestellt wird wo irgend ein
potentat sozusagen sage ich nutze es
auch das freigegebene patent und mache
jetzt auch impfstoffe der qualität nicht
entsprechen wo keiner mehr kontrollieren
kann was das
[Musik]
wunderbar schön dass es einrichten
konnte vielen dank dafür heute corona
bedingt seid immer nur zu viert auf dem
feld passt ja auch ganz gut zum thema 13
fragen hier kommt die erste müssen wir
im patente freigeben um die korona
pandemie zu beenden wenn ihr sagt ja es
ist zwar hart aber notwendig dann würde
ich euch bitten geht bitte aufs grüne
feld und wenn ihr sagt nein das schadet
vielleicht sogar dann bitte aufs gelbe
fällt und bitte
[Musik]
vielen dank jetzt wissen wir wo ihr
steht aber wo steht ihr eigentlich wir
in deutschland diskutieren ja gerade
darüber was gewusst hätte dürfen und
wann die vierte impfung kommt und das
während milliarden menschen auf der welt
noch nicht mal ihre erste spritze
erhalten haben das birgt in aller erster
linie natürlich gefahr für die
gesundheit derjenigen aber auch die
gefahr für neue virus mutationen und
damit für eine ewige verlängerung der
pandemie impfdosen müssen also schneller
auch zu denjenigen menschen die das pech
haben nicht in einem reichen land zu
leben so weit sind sich viele weitgehend
einig die frage ist aber wie kriegen wir
das hin und das diskutieren wir nicht
nur bei 13 fragen das wird gerade
weltweit diskutiert ist doch ganz
einfach sagen die einen gebt die elf
patente frei bringt das know-how und die
technologie dorthin wo impfstoffe
gebraucht werden und wo man impfstoffe
produzieren na ja so einfach ist es nun
auch nicht sagen die anderen denn das
würde die forschung radikal ausbremsen
und wer sollte noch innovationen
entwickeln wenn er weiß am ende wird eh
alles verschenkt also die fronten sind
geklärt die frage heute wird sein
schaffen wir es brücken zu bauen also
gibt es eine art zwischenlösung
vielleicht sogar einen kompromiss das
werden wir am ende dieser folge sehen
jetzt erstmal die frage an euch wo
würdet ihr euch positionieren auf dem
grünen oder auf dem gelben feld und
warum schreibt uns gerne in die
kommentare
jetzt geht's los grundsätzlich gilt wie
immer wenn ihr der gegenseite in einem
punkt zustimmt dann könnt ihr gerne
einen schritt auf sie zugehen wenn ihr
sagt grundsätzlich finde ich gar nicht
so schlecht was du sagst aber in dem
fall das ist totaler quatsch könnt ihr
auch gerne einen schritt nach hinten
gehen mein ziel am ende dieser folge
sollte es sein möglichst viele von euch
hier vorne in der mitte im sogenannten
kompromiss feld zu versammeln mal sehen
ob er das heute hinkriegt ich bin sehr
gespannt 13 fragen hier kommt frage
nummer 2 und die geht an stefan du hast
ja einen relativ guten überblick über
die internationale gesundheitslage auch
nicht zuletzt in ärmeren ländern warum
ist es aus deiner sicht so wichtig die
patente freizugeben wir werden aus der
pandemie nicht rauskommen wenn nicht
weltweit viel viel mehr menschen oder
auch alle menschen im grunde genommen
zugang zu impfungen
momentan brauchen wir einfach mehr
impfstoff wir brauchen ihn jetzt schnell
aber die hersteller kommen mit der
produktion nicht nach die freigabe von
patenten wäre ein instrument mit dem man
ermöglichen würde das mehr hersteller
impfstoffe produzieren könnten und somit
auch mehr impfstoff zur verfügung stehen
würde wir befinden uns in dieser
pandemie in einem absoluten
ausnahmezustand wir müssen hier wirklich
jedes instrument nutzen das uns zur
verfügung steht und die kosten die
korona für die menschen weltweit haben
bedeutet für die wirtschaft aber auch
für die für die persönliche gesundheit
sind so hoch dass sie tatsächlich im
gewinn und profit interessen in den
schatten stellen klingt doch wahnsinnig
plausibel manfred warum stimmst du nicht
zu ich stehe deshalb nicht zu weil ich
in der sache zwar grundsätzlich die
ansicht teile dass wir dieses problem
lösen können wenn wir weltweit
tatsächlich allen menschen eine impfung
zukommen lassen das bedeutet wir müssen
tatsächlich in kurzer zeit milliarden
von impfdosen produzieren aber dabei
muss sichergestellt sein wirksamkeit
unbedenklichkeit und die pharmazeutische
qualität dieser impfungen es ist
niemandem geholfen wenn wir ich sage
einmal zwei drittklassige impfstoffe
haben die nicht nach den regularien wie
wir sie kennen hergestellt werden wir
sollten die ems patente nicht freigeben
weil diese patente die grundlage dafür
sind dass wir diese pandemie überwinden
werden können erst mit hilfe dieser
patente konnten wir impfstoffe in den
markt in die therapie einführen und das
muss konsequent fortgesetzt werden in
jetzt argumentieren ja zum beispiel
unternehmen wenn wir jetzt patente
freigeben dann verlieren wir das
vertrauen in patente insgesamt und
keiner hätte mal lust irgendetwas
innovatives herzustellen haben die
unternehmen recht ich glaube die haben
recht wir müssen uns daran erinnern dass
beispielsweise das mainzer unternehmen
das diesen berühmten impfstoff
entwickelt hat im grunde in seiner
entwicklung ist ging er zunächst und tue
ihm stoffe eigentlich schon so etwas wie
am abgrund stand und erst über das
investment von privatpersonen ist dieses
unternehmen in die lage gekommen
weiterzuarbeiten weiter zu forschen um
dann im richtigen moment diesen
impfstoff zu entwickeln
hätte es damals die perspektive nicht
gegeben dass wenn da was rauskommt dass
auch patentgeschützt ist hätten wir den
impfstoff nicht zur verfügung daran
müssen wir uns erinnern wer nimmt das
risiko in die hand gerade im
pharmazeutischen bereich wo die trauben
hoch hängen ja das risiko einzugehen
viel geld in die hand zu nehmen um etwas
zu entwickeln wenn am ende nicht auch
die möglichkeit hat daran sozusagen zu
verdienen aber was du sagst ist also das
patent ist nicht das problem sondern
teil der lösung so ist das eben gestern
schritt auf ihn zu
gerade bin ich ein paar schritte eher
zurückgegangen aus dem grund weil ich
nicht glaube dass es nur die
investitionen einzelner sind sondern
dass es ja schon auch die öffentliche
hand ist die forschungseinrichtung
finanziert dass es auch sehr sehr viel
grundlagenforschung braucht die nicht
einzig und alleine über
pharmaunternehmen finanziert wird
deshalb kann ich tatsächlich da nicht in
gänze mitgehen das beispiel patente
impfen und globale gerechtigkeit beim
thema corona ist ein weiteres beispiel
was zeigt das koloniale strukturen
unsere gesellschaft weiter durchziehen
und ich wünsche mir dass wir dieses
thema angehen auf vielen verschiedenen
ebenen und über patente zu diskutieren
und was für alternative möglichkeiten es
gibt es auf jeden fall ein weg und ein
wichtiger schritt von vielen und ich
sehe natürlich den aspekt dass es sehr
sehr wichtig ist anreize zu schaffen
aber ich glaube eben im zentrum sollte
das menschenrecht auf gesundheit am ende
immer stehen und nicht die
profitmaximierung und ich glaube wir
bewegen uns da auf so einem spektrum von
sehr sehr viel gewinnen und patente
freigeben bedeutet nicht gar keinen
gewinn mehr für pharmakonzerne sondern
eben weniger und deshalb kann ich glaube
ich nicht so richtig vorgehen ich kann
es argumentativ nachvollziehen bin aber
nicht ganz bei dir aber bernhard ist
schon guten schritt nach vorne gegangen
warum
es ist absolut richtig dass wir menschen
recht auf gesundheit haben es ist
absolut richtig dass wir für alle zugang
zu impfstoffen brauchen und zwar schnell
das ist nicht nur
internationale solidarität sondern es
ist das eigeninteresse damit die
pandemie
schnell zu ende kommt da ist glaube ich
ein großer konsens die frage bei den
impfstoff patenten ist wirklich die
abwägung zwischen
investitionsschutz und innovation schutz
gegenüber viel mehr produzieren und wir
sagen dieser innovations- und
investitionsschutz ist der schlüssel
dafür dass wir weiter forschen an an
medikamenten wir streiten vielleicht nur
über den weg dahin und wir sind der
meinung also die bundesregierung ist der
meinung dass wir andere instrumente
nutzen müssen um diesen weltweiten
zugang zu impfstoffen zu gewährleisten
und zwar schnell und für alle jetzt sagt
er werde ich euch beiden richtig
verstanden habe sagt er ja grundsätzlich
wollen wir natürlich patentschutz und
schutz von geistigem eigentum weiter
aufrechterhalten aber wir haben eine
weltweite ausnahme situation jetzt
springt aber ein schatten und macht für
ein paar monate die patente frei und
dann schauen wir weiter ja ich glaube
diese
ausnahmesituation die ist unzweifelhaft
da und es gibt ja in dem internationalen
rechtsrahmen dem chips abkommen auch
dafür vorschriften dass ärmere länder in
ausnahmesituationen
dann diese patente freigeben also ein
waiver ist die diskussion in dieser
situation würde es aber nicht helfen
allein wir brauchen viel mehr ist also
und das ist eigentlich dass das
ärgerliche an dieser diskussion
wir verstehen uns auf die frage patente
und verlieren darüber hinaus den blick
darauf was denn eigentlich noch
notwendig ist ein beispiel niemand ist
geholfen wenn ein patent freigegeben
würde es würde in einem afrikanischen
land produziert und es gibt keine
behörde die diesen impfstoff testen und
zu lassen kann und das ist ein beispiel
dafür dass wir viel mehr tun müssen als
nur die patente freizugeben gut aber
viel mehr tun aber als nur heißt ja auch
die patente freigeben ja und da sind wir
wieder beim ausgangspunkt damit sei es
stören wir wieder das eben das vertrauen
in diesen dieses patentsystem deswegen
sagen wir viel mehr tun plus freiwillige
patent freigabe das was wir jetzt patent
patenschaft oder partnerschaft nennen
das ist etwas was hier an gehen müssen
aber eben nicht gegen die
unternehmen sondern mit ihnen gemeinsam
überzeugt mich dass steffen
vieles richtig was wir einmal gesagt hat
aber es sind überzeugt mich nicht ich
glaube müsse noch ein bisschen zurück
gehen an den anfang also wir sprechen ja
nicht davon dass wir sagen patente
sollen jetzt überall flächendeckend
freigegeben werden und es war kein
patentschutz mehr
bestehen der vorschlag der auf dem tisch
liegt der von über 100 ländern weltweit
unterstützt wird unter anderem auch von
den vereinigten staaten
dass das abkommen was bernard schon
erwähnt hat trips sieht vor dass länder
die möglichkeit haben in der nationalen
gesetzgebung zu sagen für die dauer der
panini für produkte gegen korona es kann
also auch medikamente mit einschließen
das ist glaube ich ganz wichtig weil die
werden jetzt immer wichtiger werden
gelten erstmals für die bild für die
dauer der pandemie die band hätte nicht
in deutschland in europa in
nordamerika würde ich das natürlich
würden dass die staaten nicht machen
also deutschland würde jetzt nicht sagen
diesen waiver diese ausnahmegenehmigung
die setzen wir jetzt in nationales recht
um das heißt also in allen
industrienationen wäre noch genug profit
zu machen für diese für die pharmafirmen
und ist ja momentan wird ausgerechnet
pro sekunde 1000 dollar gewinn für die
herrscher der vakzine die wir momentan
gegen koubek mainz haben was man aber
ermöglichen würde ist wenn man sagt nur
es gibt länder in denen es
produktionskapazitäten gibt die auch auf
einem gewissen genau auf dem standard
den wir brauchen produzieren können die
könnten sozusagen noch zusätzlich in die
produktion einsteigen und einfach dienen
die das angebot an impfstoffen erhöhen
direkte antwort danach gewesen also ganz
viel richtig und es werde noch wichtiger
werden wir eine internationale impfstoff
knappheit hätten die wir nicht mehr
haben wir haben ein großes
verteilungsproblem eine große
ungerechtigkeit im zugang aber der
engpassfaktor ist nicht mehr das zu
wenig impfstoff produziert wird die aber
das argument ist ja wenn man impfstoff
an verschiedenen produktionsstandorten
herstellen könnte dann wäre auch das
verteilungsproblem ein geringeres der
zugang ist in der tat dort am
niedrigsten keine produktion gibt
deswegen müssen wir das ändern wir
streiten ja nur über freiwillig oder
nicht freiwillig in kooperation mit der
industrie oder gegen die industrie
antwort von den
heute so schülers beantwortet ja es gibt
auch vieles zu beantworten wir haben ja
auch verschiedene perspektiven hier
schon ausgetauscht ja ich versuche mal
das ganze nochmal also ein schritt
zurück oder eine ebene nach oben und
zwar durch die brille von strukturellen
ungleichheiten rassismus und kolonialen
kontinuitäten weil ich glaube es ist
ganz ganz wichtig dass wir das in dieser
diskussion nicht aus dem blick verlieren
dass es nicht aus zufall passiert ist
dass diese unternehmen in europa sitzen
dass es da eine große marktmacht gibt
sondern dass das konsequenz ist
kolonialer ausbeutung
strukturen es gab nicht immer
patentrechte die integriert wurden in
die in die wto sondern ist eine
entscheidung die getroffen wurde wto
welthandelsorganisation ja und auch
nicht getroffen von ländern des globalen
südens zwangsläufig sondern eben von
starker pharmalobby gelenkt auch durch
die usa und durch die industriestaaten
die überhaupt dass ihr gesorgt haben das
trifft erst mal teil wird der wto und
ich glaube das ist schon mal sehr sehr
wichtig in der kontinuität zu sehen weil
es gab damals schon widerstände und
damals schon nicht
regierungsorganisationen aktivistinnen
insbesondere aus den ländern des
globalen südens die das kommen sehen
haben was der preis sein wird und der
preis sind am ende menschen leben und
man sieht es sehr sehr gut wenn man noch
mal zurück schaut und sich die hiv
beziehungsweise aids anguckt was dort
historisch passiert ist was ist passiert
die preise der entwickelten medikamente
waren einfach so hoch dass inkonsequenz
einfach sehr sehr viele menschen sich
diese nicht leisten konnten und ich
glaube es einfach sehr sehr wichtig dass
im blick zu behalten und da nicht so
zurückzuschrecken und so zu tun als wäre
es schon immer so gewesen sondern das
patentrecht gibt ist eine entscheidungen
die getroffen wurde von einem bestimmten
teil der welt und die so auch gewisse
machtverhältnisse kontinuierlich
aufrechterhält und länder im globalen
süden auch angewiesen sind auf
initiative kovacs oder gar weil man
sonst auch nichts machen kann sozusagen
aber diese entscheidung haben sie nicht
selbst getroffen und ich glaube es ist
sehr sehr sehr sehr wichtig das heißt so
schließt daraus auch wegen einer sagen
wir mal einer strukturellen ungleichheit
die sich über nach deiner argumentation
nach über jahrhunderte hin zementiert
hat wäre es jetzt an der zeit zu sagen
komm wir geben ist die patente frei
schließlich sind wir diejenigen die euch
ausgebeutet haben habe ich das richtig
verstanden ja ich glaube nicht nur jetzt
sondern diese frage stellt man sich
immer mal wieder in der historie sei
dass das patentrecht gibt und ich glaube
jetzt haben wir eine globale panini
jetzt kommt diese frage wieder auf aber
das ist keine frage die mir eingefallen
ist sondern es ist eine frage die uns
schon seit jahrzehnten beschäftigt jetzt
die frage an euch braucht euch auch
schon der kopf oder seid ihr ein
bisschen schlauer geworden auf welcher
seite würdet ihr euch jetzt gerade
positionieren schreibt es uns gerne in
die kommentare und manfred ist nach
vorne gegangen warum ich bin deshalb
nach vorne gegangen weil gibt beiden
beiträge von steffen und auch von dir
aus meiner sicht in vielerlei hinsicht
berechtigt sind bei dir gefällt mir
dieser ansatz dass du sagst wir müssen
das global lösen dieses problem und da
bin ich ganz bei dir wir müssen
tatsächlich darauf achtgeben dass jene
die auch benachteiligt war nicht zuletzt
aus der geschichte und ich muss das
nicht alles wiederholen was du gesagt
dass man war ja auch vieles richtig dass
da auch reagiert wird und ich glaube da
wird auch reagiert weil es kann auch
nicht sein dass ein impfstoff der
beispielsweise in europa 20 euro pro
impfdosis kostet ich sage mal der preis
ist der in südafrika in tunesien oder in
ägypten aufgerufen wird oder in anderen
ländern auf dieser welt ja einmal mehr
sagen muss dass astrazeneca auch noch
teurer verkaufen danach sind
aber auch und das ist auch eine wahrheit
ja bereits jetzt schon belastbare
abmachungen wonach qualitativ
hochwertige impfstoffe die auch in
ausreichender menge zur verfügung stehen
zu günstigen preisen angeboten werden
ich glaube nicht dass wir haben das
problem zu sein wir müssen aufpassen
dass wir nicht eine falsche diskussion
führen war den schutz hat uns die
impfstoffe gebracht und wir brauchen
jetzt steffen da hast du
hundertprozentig recht eine globale
lösung aber sagen wir doch da gemeinsam
dafür dass wir ich sag mal ich nenne es
afrika eine eine situation schaffen wo
tatsächlich plattformen entstehen die
auch in zukunft sicherstellen dass
impfstoffe vor ort zuverlässig
hergestellt werden das betrachte ich als
unsere aufgabe da sollten wir viel
investieren auch in politischen
gesprächen in abmachungen und uns und
ich habe das gefühl da geht was ihr die
richtige richtung aber ich glaube zu
sagen bei den schutzweg und das problem
ist gelöst das ist nicht
die position noch einmal klar kennen da
könnt ihr dann sofort dagegen schießt
nehmen wir doch mal an wir leben in
einer anderen welt und der patentschutz
würde jetzt fallen als ausnahmeregelung
wegen der aktuellen weltweiten notlage
dann glaubst du ja trotzdem nicht dass
genügend impfstoff bei den menschen
ankommt die ihn brauchen warum nicht
weil wir sehen und dafür gibt es
belastbare ich sage mal daten dass es
nicht so einfach ist um ein beispiel zu
nennen einen m rna impfstoff der sehr
labil ist aufgrund seiner konstitution
gekühlt sondern produktion bis ich sage
mal zum impfling zu bringen diese
strukturen müssen verbessert und
sichergestellt werden und wenn wir das
haben können wir verfügbaren impfstoff
zur vorträge lesen und zu den menschen
bringen sind weiter nach hinten gegangen
warum
also unbeabsichtigt
ein also ich würde bin fundamental nicht
der meinung dass uns patente die
impfstoffe gebracht haben wenn wir noch
mal auf die highlights krise anfang der
2000er zurückschauen millionen menschen
gestorben täglich hunderttausend
menschen im südlichen afrika die sich
die behandlung die 10.000 us dollar pro
patient pro jahr gekostet haben nicht
leisten kann und was war da der
entscheiden der game changer es war der
wettbewerb mit generika die in indien
hergestellt wurden weil indien noch
nicht das patentsystem umsetzen musste
das heißt es konnten die preise sind bis
auf 104 100 us-dollar pro patient pro
jahr gesunken sie wurden dadurch mehr
zugänglich weil sie günstiger wurden
aber dieser wettbewerb hat auch
innovation gefördert bei der hiv aids
therapie muss man klassischerweise drei
verschiedene medikamente nehmen was aus
indien angekommen ist und das war
wirklich eine innovation ist dass diese
dreifach therapie tatsächlich in einer
pille vereinfacht wurde und das war eine
innovation die nicht über einen
patentschutz gekommen ist sondern die
tatsächlich im endeffekt hervorgebracht
wurde durch an den wettbewerb und weil
es gar keine anreize gehabt für
westliche firmen sich damit zu
beschäftigen eine solche eine solche
fälle eine solche innovation für die
menschen die leider nicht genug
kaufkraft haben zu entwickeln in indien
hat waren aber diese anreize da weil sie
gesehen haben wir machen lieber mit der
masse der menschen geld die uns brauchen
anstatt auf wenige reiche zu setzen also
das argument es fehlen der patentschutz
kann auch innovationen hervorbringen ja
haben wir mit jedem fall in dem fall ist
das plausibel
bislang verwechselst du äpfel mit birnen
und zwar deshalb weil ich es ist alles
richtig was du gesagt hast nun müsste
man auch dazusagen dass die herstellung
dieser arzneimittel gegen hiv/aids
natürlich auch komplex ist aber in der
komplexität nicht vergleichbar sind mit
der herstellung eines m rna ihm stoffe
dass das heißt alleine zu sagen ich
lasse jetzt das patent fallen und jeder
kann machen mit dem patent was er will
ist nicht so einfach weil die produktion
dieses impfstoffes ist wirklich
schwierig da braucht man wirklich viel
know how und es wäre niemandem geholfen
keinem ihm klingt dieser welt würden wir
im stoffe produzieren die nicht den
erfordernissen entsprechen die wir eben
an impfstoff bestellen aber weißt du
schließt komplett aus dass man außerhalb
von europa oder usa impfstoffe
herstellen kann die diesen ansprüchen
genügen das schließlich nicht aus aber
es sind die notwendigen voraussetzungen
dafür müssen gegeben sein ja wir
brauchen natürlich ein system wo der der
herstellt auch kontrolliert wird ja das
ist ein ganz entscheidendes element ja
es ist ja wenn der sich heute ansieht
wie nach einem gültigen europäischen
arzneimittel recht impfstoffe
hergestellt wenn dann ist das wirklich
ein system das einer strengen kontrolle
unterliegt ich will nicht ich sage mal
mit einem impfstoff geimpft werden der
in einem land hergestellt wird wo irgend
ein potentat sozusagen sagt ich muss
jetzt auch das freigegeben hat und mache
jetzt auch impfstoffe der qualität nicht
entsprechen wo keiner mehr kontrollieren
kann was das heißen ja du bist
vielleicht dran aber erst bist du nicht
nur noch mal einbringen weil ich glaube
ist es auch einfach wichtig dass nicht
aus dem blick zu verlieren weil oder
andersrum ich frage dich verhindert denn
die freigabe von patenten das
technologietransfer passiert also das
klingt immer nach so einem entweder oder
und ich glaube wir sind uns hier alle
einig dass die patent freigabe nicht das
einzige ist es ist ein schritt du hast
es als ein instrument von sehr sehr
vielen bezeichnet und die frage ist oder
meine frage an dich ich weiß nicht ob
sie stellen das ist was glaubst du denn
was passiert wenn die patente
freigegeben werden mit bezug auf diesen
notwendigen technologie transfer von
denen wir alle sprechen ich glaube da
sind wir sofort einer meinung also ich
bin dafür die patente sozusagen so zu
belassen wie sie sind aber ich bin auch
dafür und da bin ich hundertprozentig
bei dir dass wir alles daransetzen
technologietransfer zu betreiben jetzt
dass bernhard die ganze sache jetzt
kommen wir an den punkt reicht es auf
die freiwillige kooperation der
unternehmen zu setzen oder müssen wir
das eben zwangsweise machen und das ist
glaube ich der einzige und nicht
vielleicht der einzige aber der
hauptpunkt wo wir unterschiedlich sind
und weil wir die kooperation der
unternehmen aus unserer sicht brauchen
und weil wir
unternehmertum brauchen wir brauchen
diesen forschergeist das wofür die leute
ausgezeichnet werden mit
bundesverdienstkreuze nja will ich auch
noch mal erinnern daran was wir
einerseits würdigen können wir doch
nicht durch den die enteignungs gleichen
eingriff so sagen die juristen werden
dann
kompliziert aber so ist es den
enteignungs gleichen eingriff dann auch
unterlaufen ich glaube dass auch völlig
unstrittig glaube ich niemand will jetzt
irgendwie biontech ans bein pinkeln im
gegenteil alle sind ganz froh dass diese
gute forschung in deutschland
vonstattenging wäre wer weiß wo wir
stünden wenn es sowas wie bei uns nicht
gegeben hätte weltweit auch gesehen ich
glaube das ist unstrittig aber du hast
jetzt natürlich einen heiklen punkt an
gesprächen gesprochen allein der begriff
enteignungs gleiche eingriff eingriffe
da bist du
zurückgeschreckt ja einfach weil ich das
kann man also das stimmt einfach nicht
mehr also sozusagen das was auf dem
tisch liegt wäre keine enteignung jetzt
nochmals es ist sagt ein entwicklung
vielleicht fragen die finanzstärke
märkte märkte für während für alle
firmen die derzeit produzieren gesichert
ja also sich jetzt nicht so dass dann
hier in deutschland irgendwann auf
einmal im wettbewerb besteht und wir
angst haben müssten dass bei uns
sozusagen habe er hat recht es geht um
einen harten eingriff in die
unternehmerische freiheit das beste
mittel wäre wenn wirklich alle firmen
sagen wir geben die technologien weiter
wir transferieren ist wir arbeiten mit
allen zusammen die die es wollen und
dann werden auch die qualitäts standards
gehalten aber wie gesagt wir sehen dass
jetzt das dass diese impfstoffe seit
über einem jahr existierenden ist noch
nicht genug passiert wir sind bei
durchschnittlich zehn prozent geimpften
menschen auf dem afrikanischen kontinent
es ist zu wenig ich und auch oder sogar
freiwilligkeit dass wir nicht mit
freiwilligkeit nicht sozusagen dem
schritt machen indem wir machen müssen
und wir reden auch nur über eine kurze
zeit nur weil hoffentlich kurze zeit bis
diese pandemie beendet ist so jetzt
wissen wir wer werden gleich noch ein
bisschen weiter springen aber manfred
ist auch schon am zocken und für dich
einmal die frage über gespiegelt also
kannst du dir ein szenario vorstellen
nehmen wir an die impfstoff verteilung
läuft weiter schlecht wir leben in einem
halben jahr immer noch in einer welt in
der viel zu wenig menschen geimpft sind
kannst du dir vorstellen dass auch du zu
irgendwas so ein punkt aus sachsen
enteignungs gleicher eingriff bzw 1
andere sagen ein milder eingriff in die
unternehmerische freiheit ohne dass
irgendjemand davon abend wird ist
vorstellbar für ich will dich bitte die
zunächst darauf setzen dass man das auch
im sinne von freiwilligem ton erreicht
und ich bin mir sehr sicher dass das an
der stelle auch funktionieren wird wir
haben es kurz angerissen es ging um
öffentliche gelder die große frage zum
beispiel wir nehmen das nur als beispiel
firma es ist tut mir leid aber das
kennen halt eine band hat ungefähr 400
millionen euro von der öffentlichen hand
bekommen das heißt von uns allen
steuergeld um das ganze zum fliegen zu
bringen da gibt es die argumentation
naja wenn wir uns daran zumindest in
geringem maße beteiligt haben warum kann
dann die firma nicht ein bisschen was zu
allgemeinheit zurückgeben habe ich das
drin richtig verstanden unter anderem ja
und auch zu sagen dass sozusagen nur
aufgrund der erwarteten gewinne durch
die monopolstellung die durch potente
geschaffen wird dass nur dass forschung
und entwicklung sozusagen anreize setzt
das in dem würd ich halt wieder sprechen
fiel der grundlagenforschung wird
öffentlich finanziert und in diesem fall
wurde halt tatsächlich auch von der
öffentlichen hand ein unternehmen das
jetzt vakzine herstellt und ein patient
hat auch finanziert oder unterstützt
kann das nachvollziehen
na klar der gedanke liegt nahe das würde
aber bedeuten dass wir überall wo wir
fördern auch den zugriff auf die patente
und statt mit der förderung
praktisch erkaufen und das ist glaube
ich kontraproduktiv wir alle wollen
forschung um der forschung und der
forschungsergebnisse werden aber wir
wollen nicht damit dem zugriff auf das
unternehmen ewe ist ein stückchen zurück
gegangen habe ich gemerkt wem gehören
die patente deine meinung ja ich bin
zurück gegangen also überall gesagt hast
im sinne von überall wo die öffentliche
hand was rein gibt möchte sie dann auch
anteile am patentrecht haben da bin ich
sehr sehr weit zurückgegangen weil noch
mal wir sprechen nicht von überall und
immer sondern wir sprechen von der
globalen notsituation und von einem
temporären aussetzen dieser patente bis
diese situation hoffentlich bald vorbei
ist und um noch mal deine frage genauer
zu beantworten ich glaube ich schon dass
wenn es sehr viele gelder aus der
öffentlichen hand kommen da auch immer
die frage ist woran wird sich orientiert
also wird sich eben orientiert hat mir
von menschenrecht gesundheit globale
verantwortung wo liegt das interesse vor
allen dingen wer bestimmt wo dieses
interesse liegt und wer entscheidet wo
dieses interesse liegt ich glaube wenn
da eben die öffentliche hand somit der
steuerzahler und der staat sich stärker
einbringen sollten auch interessen des
globalen südens eine größere rolle
spielen und eben nicht alleine
innovation und pharmaindustrie
manfred ich glaube hier wird vergessen
dass das unternehmen das mainzer
unternehmen
ich habe gar keine zweifel dass der
öffentliche mittel geflossen sind
allerdings zu einem zeitpunkt wo der
impfstoff schon da war das wollen wir
schon an der stelle festhalten
daneben jetzt betrachtet entschuldigung
ganz ganz kurz und wurde schon ganz am
anfang auch vom bundesministerium für
forschung gefördert mit ein paar
millionen ich glaube vier oder fünf
millionen und als dann der impfstoff
mehr oder weniger da waren flossen noch
einmal 380 ja aber es ist auch eine
wahrheit dass das unternehmen im grunde
am abgrund stand und es war das
investment der brüder andreas und thomas
strüngmann den letztendlich dieses
unternehmen am leben gehalten haben zu
einem zeitpunkt wo noch nicht über die
frage des vor ohne impfstoffes
gesprochen wurde sondern ging es noch um
die natura impfstoffe und dann wenn das
wenn dieses im westen nicht gekommen
wäre hätte es das unternehmen mit der
technologie in der folge nicht gegeben
das heißt die 400 millionen hätte man
gar nicht investiert hätte man nicht
investieren können dann wäre es das
unternehmen nicht mehr tragen aber das
heißt dass er irgendwann ist jetzt eine
gute oder schlechte staatliche
investition ich kenne jetzt nicht das
ausmaß der der subvention oder
unterstützung und wann die auch passiert
sind aber ich weiß eines dass das
unternehmen ja vor der ist-situation
stand zu zu machen oder einen neuen
geldgeber zu bekommen und jetzt will ich
eigentlich das sagen was ich vorhin
schon sagen wollt denn die
steuereinnahmen dieses unternehmens
beziehen die steuerabgaben die sind so
enorm dass die stadt mainz sich freund
wie ein schneekönig zahlen auf einmal
sind wir in den schwarzen zahlen sehen
denn den schwarzen tag also ist man darf
jetzt nicht so tun als würde hier keine
ein rückfluss sein das unternehmen gibt
auch erhebliche zurück du hast natürlich
vollkommen recht vor allem in der
pharma-branche spielen private
investitionen die größte rolle ganz
eindeutig prozentual gesehen ist es
eindeutig so nun ist nun ist es aber
fakt dass wir 400 millionen euro
steuergeld in zum beispiel bei uns
eingeschlagen haben und die frage war ja
hat dann nicht die allgemeinheit
vielleicht doch zumindest ein kleines
mitspracherecht wenn es um verantwortung
in der welt geht
du hast deine meinung schon gesagt also
ich glaube mitspracherecht im sinne von
du musst jetzt ein patent auf geben
nicht aber natürlich und wir machen das
hier ja im grunde auch dass wir einen
dialog darüber führen wie können wir das
problem lösen es ist ja nicht so dass
wir in der globalen frage auseinander
sind wir wir wollen die krise überwinden
das ist der punkt aber es ist nicht das
patent der patentschutz das problem
sondern andere probleme müssen gelöst
werden die müssen angegangen werden
du wolltest du wolltest doch ich glaube
schon das ist ein hindernis so nochmals
patente sind wichtig ich glaube nicht
dass wir die fr den schutz und das
system abschaffen sollten nur es gibt
hier und da
situationen wo er uns nicht hilft wo er
sozusagen auch für die öffentliche
gesundheit tatsächlich vielleicht nicht
die beste lösung ist und es gibt
weltweit produktionsstätten die auch im
ehrenhain stoffe herstellen könnten zu
der qualität die wir haben wollen aber
jetzt ist natürlich es gibt keine
investoren diese einmal die notwendigen
investitionen die auch in diesen
produktionskapazitäten noch getätigt
werden müssten
diese investition kommen nicht weil ja
immer noch nicht klar ist dürfen die
überhaupt produzieren ich glaube wenn
man sagen würde wir folgt mit diesem
vorschlag von der von über 100 staaten
der welt und den vereinigten staaten
unterstützt wird und geben die patente
auf
medikamente impfstoffe und so weiter
frei in bezug auf die korona pandemie
dann würden wir investoren sehen die
tatsächlich in diese
produktionskapazitäten investieren
würden und die nötigen anpassungen somit
finanzieren würden aber wären als
argument ist ja noch nicht mal als
ultima ratio kann man noch nicht mal
zeitlich begrenzt patente freigeben weil
man das vertrauen in den patentschutz
dermaßen beschädigt dass wir uns damit
das nächste und vielleicht viel größere
probleme einhandeln deswegen gehe ich
einen schritt auf ihn zu weil also
ultima ratio am ende ist es vielleicht
doch ein instrument und da
sagen sagen wir auch also wir setzen auf
die freiwillige kooperation wenn das
jetzt nicht kommt dann müssen wir das
nochmal uns genau angucken kurze frage
wie lange wollt ihr denn noch gucken 20
22 und dann oder 2022 also ich würde
sagen nicht verwenden wir können die
sendung gerne in einem halben jahr
wiederholen halbes jahr ist eine gute
frist wie geht's euch nach dieser
diskussion
könntet ihr euch vorstellen wenn ihr am
drücker sees ihr dürftet entscheiden
könnt ihr euch vorstellen patente
freizugeben als allerletztes mittel so
wie es bernhard formuliert oder als
sogar vor vor letztes mittel so wie es
die grüne seite formuliert gerade könnt
ihr euch das vorstellen ja oder nein
warum ist das so also begründet gerne
eure entscheidung und schreibt uns in
die kommentare ich würde ganz gerne
nochmal manfred dazu holen mit einem
neuen twist es gibt ja einen vielleicht
neuen impfstoff namens kombi wächst oder
grob wex erforscht in texas ein
sogenannter open source impfstoff der
mit absicht eben nicht patentiert wurde
damit er freigegeben werden kann es ist
noch nicht ganz klar wie wird es aber
offenbar erste studien zeigen ob man
eine hohe wirksamkeit bei gleichzeitig
sehr günstiger und einfacher produktion
das ganze hat angeblich gekostet 9
millionen euro privat geld also
vergleichsweise gar nichts
ist das nun nicht der beweis dass wenn
man impfstoffe von der
profitorientierung abkoppelt sie doch
für alle zugänglich sein können ich
glaube dass das gut ist dass wir
zunächst einmal diese technologie die
schon sehr alt ist auch einsetzen um
impfstoffe zu entwickeln dass das jetzt
freigegeben wird finde ich auch in
ordnung diese impfstoffe von der du
jetzt gesprochen hast also diese
rekombinanten protein basierten
arzneistoffe die sind deshalb eine
chance auch für die gesamte welt weil
sie auch leichter hergestellt werden
können diese technologie kann man viel
leichter auch in weniger
industrialisierten ländern herstellen
deshalb ist alles daran zu setzen dass
das auch vorangetrieben wird ich warne
davor zu sagen dass das jetzt sozusagen
das allein seligmachende ist gerade bei
diesem konkreten beispiel mit blick auf
das was wir uns wünschen wir samels
sichere und in der pharmazeutischen
qualität auch entsprechende impfstoffe
zu haben mir fehlen dann noch viele
klinische daten die tatsächlich belegen
dass die wirksamkeit da ist aber
grundsätzlich ist gegen diese
entwicklung nichts zu sagen weil es auch
ein wichtiger schritt ist um die
pandemie zu bekämpfen aber die
qualitätsstandards oyten in allen
belangen die ich genannt habe
eingehalten werden okay jetzt haben wir
ein paar sehr konstruktiver vorschläge
schon ausgetauscht hier steht auch
relativ weit vorne alle manfred es so
auf halber halber höhe noch nicht ganz
voll ist aber auch gar nicht schlimm
jeder darf hier stehen wo er will oder
wo sie will wir wollen jetzt in die
kompromiss runde gehen ich mach mal
einen einen kompromissvorschlag der sagt
wenn der staat wie zum beispiel im falle
von biontech eine gehörige menge geld in
die hand nimmt und es geht um
gesundheitsprodukte und zu diesem
zeitpunkt wusste man auch wir laufen in
eine pandemie rein wir nehmen ganz viel
geld in die hand und machen uns
vertraglich ein ganz kleines
hintertürchen wir kommen in eine notlage
wie wir sie jetzt haben dann hätten wir
ein so eine art vorkaufsrecht auf eine
lizenz zum beispiel niemand soll dabei
arm werden also bei uns schon mal gar
nicht und auch die ganzen zulieferer
nicht aber wir hätten eine kleine chance
zu sagen wir schnappen uns jetzt 34
lizenzen und geben sie günstig weiter in
die welt das ist der kompromissvorschlag
wenn ihr sagt finde ich gar nicht so
schlecht würde ich den schritt vorgehen
oder wenn ihr sagt kain nichts mit
anfangen bleibt hier stehen oder geht
sogar zurück
bernhard geht davon
ich gehe auch von du bist zu halten von
ihrer freundin schreibt er weiter
natürlich der konsens drinsteckt nur das
unternehmen was die fördermittel annimmt
musste ich ja und hat sie rüsten sich
die verträge durchlesen und wenn sie mit
dieser bedingungen einverstanden sind
dann sind sie in freiwillig dabei ja das
ist ein geben und nehmen und das ist für
mich das entscheidende das ist eben
konsensual in einer in einer
partnerschaft ist ein ultra komplexer
vertrag den man auf setzen ist sehr
wahrscheinlich sowieso konnte halt noch
eine seite mehr drauf und da steht das
drin und das ist wenn es im vertrag
geregelt ist total in ordnung gut du
bist auch so ein bisschen nach vorne
gegangen wäre eine möglichkeit
findet das nicht so gut doch nicht ja
ich hänge einfach auch noch mal in
diesem aspekt von konsens und mit der
frage wer eben in den bestimmt und
wessen interessen da im vordergrund
stehen und auch nochmal wir sprechen
heute wirklich über die globale
perspektive nicht ausschließlich über
die deutsche deshalb bin ich mir nicht
sicher inwiefern praktisch ein konsens
basieren auf den interessen eines
deutschen staates und eines deutschen
unternehmens wirklich die globale
perspektive im blick behalten kann
ferner ferner so jetzt seid ihr dran
jeweils steckt doch mal ein bisschen die
köpfe zusammen corona gerecht natürlich
also jeweils in euren gruppen denkt euch
mal 23 minuten was aus vielleicht einen
satz einen vorschlag womit ihr die
anderen überzeugen könnte merkt euch
bitte eure position ja damit wir
ungefähr wissen wo gewann und jetzt
geht's los
den starken staaten prepared sind das
wirklich tatsächlich die welt feierte
chris
jahre spannende diskussionen wie immer
was würdet ihr dann sagen habt ihr aus
dieser diskussion heraus eine idee
entwickelt wurde sagt hey so würden die
beiden seiten noch enger zusammen kommt
das wäre vielleicht eine lösung auch für
zukünftige pandemien dann schreibt es
gerne in die kommentare
[Musik]
ihr könnt ja auch noch mal eine halbe
sekunde über den vorschlag nachdenken
den ihr gleich formulieren wollt denn
die gelbe seite steht schon länger
bereit also gelb was ist euer vorschlag
wie schafft ihr es dass die beiden mehr
auf euch zukommen
also wir sind uns absolut eigentlich
dass wir ganz viel gleichzeitig tun
müssen um mehr impfstoff weltweit zu
verteilen das ist das unbestrittene ziel
und dazu müssen wir wie gesagt mehr hin
stoffe in die internationalen
verteilungsmechanismen kovacs geben wir
müssen auch mehr produktionsstätten
aufbauen dazu setzen wir immer noch auf
kooperation mit der industrie ja und auf
unterstützung der
systeme vor ort und wo wir nicht ganz
beieinander sind ich habe ja eben schon
gesagt wir würden uns das einen
bestimmten zeitraum noch angucken und
müssen dann evaluieren ob wir mit der
freiwilligkeit weit wirklich zum
ergebnis kommen und wenn wir merken dass
die unternehmen nicht beziehen dann
müssen wir vielleicht noch mal über
diese frage gesondert nachdenken da bist
du nicht ganz einig du bist radikal
dagegen richtig ich habe ihn jetzt nicht
gegen diese vorschläge ich sage nur dass
der patentschutz nicht das problem ist
sondern wir haben andere probleme er hat
die gelöst werden müssen dass wir hier
in einem boot sitzen und nicht sozusagen
alleine agieren können ist auch völlig
klar wir müssen solidarisch agiert
weltweit ich habe ich muss das einfach
vor unseren konsens noch mal sagen weil
du ganz klar jetzt noch mal gesagt dass
das patentschutz und das patentrecht
nicht das problem ist und ich glaube wir
sind uns einig dass patente nicht die
einzige lösung sind aber auch diese
planung ist nicht die letzte uns gibt
auch nach wie vor andere krankheiten
über die wir blenden sprechen könnten wo
eben doch das patentrecht mit eine
verantwortung irgendwo hat dafür dass
wir da sind wo wir sind ok was ist euer
vorschlag wie kommen wir möglichst
schnell aus dieser pandemie heraus und
da denke ich sollten wir tatsächlich als
wir sollte die bundesregierung sollte
die europäische kommission sollte die
georgen der vereinigten staaten und alle
anderen einfach tatsächlich die
privatindustrie in die verantwortung
nehmen und sagen liebe freundinnen und
freunde ihr schafft jetzt in den
nächsten drei bis sechs monaten die
voraussetzungen dass wir gar nicht mehr
über diesen film war reden müssen wenn
das aber nicht passiert dann reden wir
mit den chips raver und dann kommt der
trip schwerer weil so kann es einfach
nicht weitergehen es ist nicht mehr
möglich dass wir business user machen
und da hat die privatindustrie ihre
verantwortung zu sagen ich weiß jetzt
mal zusammen wenn ich das richtig
richtig verstanden habe und eigentlich
ist es doch relativ einfach was du sagst
industrie achtung wenn ihr keinen
schritt 2 volt löst das problem so
schnell wie möglich eigentlich nach
androhung
einer notlage befinden ja also ich will
ja noch verständlich richtig verstanden
werden gut ihr beide habt ja so ganz
ähnliche sachen eigentlich gesagt du
bist nach vorn ich bin nach vorne
gegangen ich bin bereit 99 prozent
einverstanden
ich bin total dabei dass die industrie
eine verantwortung hat das weiß die
industrie auch es gibt viele kooperation
aber es muss noch mehr geben und vor
allem müssen wir diese ergebnisse sehen
und in kurzer zeit ja ich habe gemischte
gefühle ich uns natürlich den gedanken
schön dass es irgendwo ein gleiches ziel
geht da habe ich auch schon dass sie die
vorstellungen der wege und uns bei 1
zumindest ich schon so ein stück weit
unterscheiden ich glaube das was ich
heute gelernt habe ja war auch dass wir
das dass wir sozusagen bei der bewertung
der aktuellen situation beispielsweise
die geschichte nicht außer acht lassen
dürfen das hast du ja sehr stark
eingebracht und ich finde dass in
aspekte die es die müssen wir ernst
nehmen und ich gebe ehrlich zu vor der
sendung habe ich mir darüber nicht so
viele gedanken macht ja jetzt nach der
sendung mache ich mir da mehr gedanken
weil es ist nur dann die sache wirklich
lösbar wenn wir diese aspekte mit
eigentlich sind wir nur an einer stelle
noch auseinander nämlich wie lange geben
wir der industrie zeit das problem mit
ihren mitteln in partnerschaft zu lösen
ja und das war ein sehr gutes gespräch
sehr gute diskussion noch so zurückgeben
was ich fand in generell die diskussion
war sehr hohem niveau wir haben sehr
konstruktiv miteinander gesprochen haben
durchaus auch unterschiedliche
standpunkte vertreten das war uns klar
aber schön und wichtig ist tatsächlich
meiner meinung nach gewesen was rauskam
dass wir alle ein ziel haben und dass
das überhaupt nicht hinterfragt wird
dass wir diese pandemie so schnell wie
möglich beenden müssen und dass der weg
dazu ist tatsächlich allen menschen
weltweit zugang zu impfstoffen zu
gewähren herzlichen dank für die
diskussion wenn er jetzt zu hause sagt
mensch ich habe richtig was gelernt
schreibt in die kommentare oder wenn ihr
sagt alle vier liegen komplett falsch
auch das könnt ihr gerne hinterlassen
ganz herzlichen dank die 13 fragen zur
im patienten frei geben ja oder nein
danke zu machen
ich denke es ist klar geworden wer
behauptet die einen wollen menschenleben
retten und die anderen wollen nur
profite maximieren der macht es sich
etwas zu einfach die diskussion ist um
einiges komplexer auf der anderen seite
sehen wir die internationale
staatengemeinschaft hat bei der
impfstoff verteilungsprobleme prinzip
freiwilligkeit zieht offenbar nicht ganz
ich persönlich glaube staaten sollten
durchaus in die lage versetzt werden
zumindest bilde zumindest in diesen
weltweiten ausnahmesituationen stärker
in den markt eingreifen zu können wenn
euch 13 fragen gefällt dann könnt ihr
hier unseren kanal abonnieren hier gibt
es eine weitere folge und hier gibt es
ein weiteres video zum thema